moving on now and emergency workers in
germany and belgium are still searching
for hundreds of people missing after
heavy flooding
more than 150 have now been confirmed
dead that figure is expected to increase
rescue efforts are being hampered by
collapsed roads and damaged
communication lines
steph vassen reports now from the german
town of sindsig where cleanup efforts
have begun
they were trapped in their rooms on the
first floor when the water rose up to
four meters in no time
at least 12 residents of this home for
disabled people died
before they could be moved to safety
across the street gabriella walt watched
the neighborhood swiftly turn
into a swirling river and feared the
worst
in the entrance
the people on the lower floors have not
made it out i don't know exactly what
happened but the next morning those who
survived
were evacuated from their balconies it's
absolutely horrible
living in this region his whole life
hermann engel still can't comprehend
what he saw when the water came
panic i wasn't just shocked
i panicked i quickly took out the car as
well as my dog and the two cats
belonging to my daughter that we were
taking care of
this sort of destruction i've never seen
before
flooding yes but not tree branches
floating away
he was lucky enough to be moved to
safety and to find his house still
standing upon return
others saw their homes washed away by
water or destroyed by landslides
many remain missing nobody expected that
a few days of torrential rain could have
such a widespread catastrophic
impact confronted with the sheer power
of water people here are wondering what
happened and where all this water came
from
raising questions about the effects of
climate change and
if what was called this once in a
century flood would now happen
more frequently people are saying that
this might happen like for now
every 5-10 years or something like that
so
i'm not sure and i mean like we try to
learn
from this together with relatives and
friends luisa huyang is trying to clean
up the mess
at her family house not knowing where to
start
they tried to return on thursday but had
to leave once again
the water was still here we try to get
in the house and get everything
up on the like highest point in the
house
so and then we just grabbed also some
stuff that
we could see that we knew okay this is
important and then we just
left the extent of the damage won't be
known for days or perhaps weeks
but the memories and trauma of this
twist of nature
will likely remain with the people here
for much longer
and a short time ago stepp sent us this
update from bonn in germany
for the first time in days the sun came
out just a tiny bit but
evacuations are still ongoing in the
middle of the night
hundreds of people up to 700 have been
evacuated because a dam
burst near christback that's near
cologne
and the reason for that was that the
waters in the
netherlands on the other side of the
border were also so high
that they closed the floodgates there so
the water came back to germany and
really led to some serious problems at
the dam so the
the german authorities had to call to
the netherlands this is a
border region so all co of course all
the authorities are taking their own
measures and it's very difficult to
coordinate
this disaster meanwhile also evacuation
still ongoing from
nursing homes hospitals
buildings that are really damaged as
well i spoke to a person in a nursing
home
up to the second floor the water was and
there were people living above the 80s
and 90s so very dire situation still
although in some places the water is
receding in other places
it's still very high especially near the
border regions of the netherlands and
belgium
authorities are trying their best
nineteen thousand rescue workers
are on these locations at the moment the
army is trying to
get to a place in ashdod where
landslides were happening and cars
were basically swimming away with people
still in it
so the rescue workers from the army are
trying to recover
probably bodies from these cars right
now
but of course they're completely
overwhelmed and what i saw yesterday was
mainly
people helping each other and that's a
positive thing
from coming from this very dire
situation people really helping each
other lots of volunteers
also people offering help come into our
houses
offering food so there's a really
coordinated effort from the people
themselves
happening right now here in the western
part of germany
i'm still ahead here